welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to thinking
like a billionaire now you can just
watch this video or if you want to sign
up for the entire series for
free and get the bonus pdf companion
calendar
check the link in the description below
today is day 28 and we're gonna learn
how you can have
discipline like a billionaire enjoy
[Music]
i think of the these things is just
there's a certain amount of time
and within that time you want the
the best net outcome so for
you know all the set of actions that you
can do there's
going to be and some of which will fail
some which will
succeed and you want the the the net
useful output of your
set of actions to be the highest
um so
we have to like use like a baseball
analogy like
you know baseball they don't let you
just sit there and wait for the perfect
pitch
until that you get a real easy one they
didn't give you
three shots and the third one they say
okay
they get off the go back to the
put somebody else up there um so these
your three strikes on
on baseball um
like you know not only bad anymore so
so what you're what you're really
looking for is like what's the batting
average
you know how you doing on uh
on score um and and just
there's going to be some amount of
failure
but you want your net output
that useful output to be maximized
failure is
essentially irrelevant unless it is
catastrophic
better now you don't need 150 iq to do
what i do
thank god you know you don't need 140
you know 135 you may need 115 or
something like that and
and but you do need discipline you have
to wait
until you see the fat pitch to swing at
because
investing is a no-call strike game you
know if i were a baseball player
and i only like pitches two inches above
my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get called out on strikes in
baseball you have to
you have to swing at pitches that you
you don't even necessarily like
particularly after the count gets to two
strikes
in business you don't have to swing at
anything you can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 or
it says general electric at 115 or says
general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but it's a marvelous game to be
in because there are no called strikes
and you can simply wait
for that one time in a month or six
months or a year
or two or three years when you really
know what you're doing where you like
the price
where you like the people running the
business and then you swing and you only
need a few swings in your lifetime
be stubborn on vision and flexible on
details
the you really can't accomplish anything
important if you're not stubborn on
vision
because things that are important take a
long time you take teams you can't do it
by yourself
and so you really need to you need to
have a crisp idea of the vision
you need to stay incredibly relentless
on that vision
but you need to be flexible on the
details because
you've got to be experimental to
accomplish anything important
and that means you're going to be wrong
a lot and so you're going to try
something
on your way to that vision and that's
going to be the wrong thing the wrong
decision you're going to have to back up
take a little course correction and try
again
and so you cannot be stubborn on the
details
you have to be flexible on the detail
what is your decision making process
or thinking when it comes to investing
your time your money your energy
sure uh it's very important because time
is the most valuable thing you have
is one make sure where you're putting
your time and energy
is something you want to do not just
because you're exploring with people you
don't like
or a business you don't like or a
situation you don't like time is so
valuable
try and speak if you're speaking to
people or a situation
to people you feel there's hope for that
you could do something with
to do something great not just make
money
whenever you go into business or in a
relationship with someone
just to make money then it means you've
already decided to take a portion of
your time to make these papers that are
backed up by nothing but will buy
stuff to call it a possession
we have all these great possessions well
if you have these great
possessions could you give them away if
you had any possession you could give it
away
hey great it was a possession and you
moved on if you can't give that
possession away to somebody
just give it away then it possesses you
i started my first business when i was
12. i was buying and selling um baseball
cards buying and selling stamps
anything i could do to make money i was
hustling and trying to do so
i was in the business but i not so much
where it was
all my friends were into it with me so
they wouldn't know
baseball cards yeah baseball cards you
name it i mean i grew up in pittsburgh
and so i would probably even less than
12 years old i would
excuse me go up buy a bunch of baseball
cards that i collected and i would
package i would say okay you're
guaranteed to have a pittsburgh pirate
in this package and i would charge three
times as much and i'd set up on this
park bench down in the park down in
scott township where i grew up
and um i'd have these little sales and
it was great i made money and i mean it
was
you know and i learned as much about
business when i was 9 10 and 12 as i
learned any other time
fashion is changing so fast and and a
competition is coming up every day with
all these young designers
what has kept you going forward like
this
you just somehow you know i've always
admired longevity
i've admired people that uh were not of
the only moment
people that can cap can carry it on
there there are actors there are
musicians
there are people that came up in in
in rock and roll and the great ones
stayed
frank sinatra lasted you know
the whole pile of names that you know
paul mccartney and the beatles
they didn't last for five years or ten
years they lasted for 40 years
i admired longevity and i admired
consistency
and i admire the individuality of
holding your own
and standing and fighting for what you
believe in and i think if there's
anything that i really believe in is
that
and what made me keep going i didn't get
great reviews every year
i didn't people wouldn't just say you're
wonderful in fact
they couldn't care less ralph lauren but
the consumer loved ralph lauren
it's not the fashion editor but were
there moments that you felt really
you know exhausted tired of everything
with this tedious
all the details coming up to you and or
a moment
when you thought you know i could be out
you know
no new ideas coming to me anymore were
there those moments
no never no there were moments when i
i always thought what i was doing was
what i loved
i i try to do what i love so basically
you're saying
you have never been tired of this sure
you know um but the capability
to adapt to the changes of people's
taste desire lifestyle
you know i'm i'm competitive i love
i love i love competition and i love
what i'm doing
and i love the fact that i'm not
following
if i started to follow then i would quit
so what's motivated me is nunes
is energy to change the awareness that
things move on maybe because i have a
family
young people always and and in my
company
i listen to people just just like the
man that didn't listen to me when i
wanted to get another job
in the thai business you know i don't
want to make that mistake
and so i i'm inspired by young people
i'm inspired by newness i'm inspired by
the challenge of building a business
that no one ever built before it's not
only the
artistic part of it it's the excitement
of
what can i do that i haven't done before
what were some of the most challenging
moments in your career
well i had when i started out and made
the ties and shirts
i started to become successful it was
about after about 10 years
i hired i had started my company by
borrowing 50
000 from another person in the industry
he let me the fifty thousand became my
partner and so
all of a sudden we were growing and
and all of a sudden i got a phone call
from a banker and said miss lauren
your bills are not being paid on time
and um i had a team thinking they were
doing
all the right things and all of a sudden
i found that i was in trouble
financially because i was taking on too
many things and no one told me
to stop and i
was being applauded from many ways but
on
some levels on the financial level i was
not being applauded
and one of the bankers came to me and
said
ralph you're almost out of business
what are you going to do that was 10
years after you started that was about
10 years after i started but i remember
the pain and
and i took everything i had saved which
was a hundred thousand dollars
and i put it back in the company 100 000
was all i had
left and and so and i decided to license
some of the brands and have some money
coming in and so
it gave me a shot to to go out and hire
better people and
and so that was a very important moment
of seeing success in terms of
artistic success but failure in terms of
of a company that could go wrong
in its num in its finances and that was
a
very important time and
so that was a very major moment
in my life i've had those every five
years i
had a show where i remember doing a
fashion show and the clothes weren't
ready and
the tailors were ironing or sewing the
clothes as the girl is about to walk out
the runway
what did you figure out what happened to
to make it so late
of not getting the right professionals
not not planning well
not thinking you got it going and all of
a sudden
i said to myself as i was walking
on on broadway not knowing where i was
going i said this is never
going to happen again everything you try
to do
is already done so when i figured that
out
oh what i'm putting out is what's coming
back
let me get real clear about what it is
i'm putting out
real clear so i read a book
about 1989 called seed of the soul and
in that book gary zukov talked about
the laws of karma
of the laws of cause and effect
the third law of motion and in that book
he talked about
how intention your intention
is always one
with the law meaning before you
even think about a thing you have an
intention for the thing
and that the intention is going to
determine
the outcome that's why the same people
can go to the same church service
and somebody walked down the aisle just
to be seen
to put some money in the
church and somebody else who just goes
and just has a little bit to offer
the intention with which you give
the intention with which you serve
determines the outcome so when i
figured that out i went whoa
i changed everything i did on my show
i called in the producers and i said
from this day
forward i will no longer be speaking to
the kkk
i will no longer be speaking to people
who are fighting each other in a way
that it is damaging to the character of
myself and other people who watch
from this day forward i am only going to
do
intentional television i learned my
management skill
one day i was talking to the uh the
famous general
uh of the united states
he was talking to this group of people
say
how do you discipline your lieutenant
he's a general the guy who lead
the first iraq war what's his poll
called polling yeah poland he said you
as a leader you have to get up early
before the lieutenant
you have to sleep before the lieutenant
late
before after the lieutenant you have to
eat
before the uh after the lieutenant to
eat but if they have a problem with the
lieutenant what are you going to do
fix him remove him and fight him
i told many people when they joined
alibaba
i say guys i don't know fortunate or
unfortunate to enjoy alibaba
we work much longer than the others
much harder we had more problems than
most of the companies
if you can survive in alibaba you can
survive at any company in the world
because life is tough i apologize in
advance for the sports reference
but i would say get in the weight room
the weight room of life
what do you do in a weight room if
you're an athlete
or a kind of retired senior citizen like
me
you prepare you prepare
you build new capabilities you get
stronger
you get faster you figure out how to get
leverage and yet in your business lives
those are precisely the right messages
one of the things that i think has made
microsoft the company that is today
is that we weren't afraid to get in the
weight room
in the late 80s we had plenty of
customers
investors tell us we would quote never
be an
enterprise company today
many people think the bulk of the 350
billion of value in microsoft
is in our enterprise business we weren't
afraid to sit there even before we had
it figured out
and just work to prepare to get better
to build new capabilities
and whether we're talking about what you
need to do for your startup
for the hospital that you join or for
yourself
personally you have to build new
capabilities
new quickness and new leverage i feel
like hustle is
the willingness to work really really
hard and then also
your willingness to get the job done
like
um kind of navigating and doing what it
takes
and um and so
i yeah i've there's so much about my
journey where i was like i am not going
to let the outcome
or my success be contingent on other
people
as much as i can control it help it
navigate it i'm going to
so um so yeah in the beginning
especially still now i mean obviously
i'm hustling i'm like at the at
this where i am now and i'm running
around the airport asking people to
follow me on instagram you know
uh i just feel like it's innate in me
also to a degree
um but the uh in the beginning
ex like there's a few examples that come
to mind you mentioned that i paid my i
called my friends and asked them to go
buy spanx and i
wrote everybody checks and sent them a
check
because i needed to drive momentum and i
had no money to advertise so i'm like
this product is going to sit on the
shelf so i need to get
people to go in and buy it i also when i
went into the stores i realized very
quickly that
my product was in the sleepiest part of
the department store it was back in the
corner and nobody was going there
so then i immediately
went to target and i bought
um envelope dividing dividers that you
put on your home desk
and i ran around neiman marcus and put
them at every register
and i put spanx in them and then i
walked away
and neiman's has like impeccable visual
rules and regulations and um and i did
that because i had to get my product out
of the department and because i did that
women in
shoes started buying spanx and women in
contemporary and
and um those decisions made such a big
difference and
by the time somebody figured out that
nobody else had approved it
because you know everybody thought
somebody else approved it um
it was so successful that the head of
neiman's was like whatever this girl's
doing let her keep doing it
being an entrepreneur isn't just a job
title
it isn't just about starting a company
it's about a state of mind
it's about seeing connections others
can't
seizing opportunities others won't and
forging new directions that others
haven't
it's about being entrepreneurial
wherever you are and in whatever you do
it's about having the courage to give
into a passion
for an idea that makes your heart race
and if it doesn't scare you
the idea isn't big enough here's what
i've learned
we may live in an age of instant
messaging
instant gratification and instagram
but there is no way to short circuit the
path to success
it takes hard work tenacity and a lot of
patience
there are many things you can do
overnight you can
write a decent paper you can put
finishing touches on a fashion show
i hear you can even have a pretty good
time at rogers pub
but there is no such thing as an
overnight success
it is a myth that glosses over what
being an entrepreneur is all about
as biz stone one of the founders of
twitter's put it
timing perseverance and 10 years of
really hard work
will eventually make you look like an
overnight success
i have to give something up there has to
be a price to pay
and again i'm not suggesting that i know
everything i'm not suggesting that this
is right for you i am suggesting that
in my life at 58 years old i know that i
have to give something up
okay i've always had to give something
up so i'm always right i'm looking at
what are the habits
that i've gotten into now okay when i
was 25 years old when i was 24 years old
smoking weed every day every
every day man woke up to the weed man i
would smoke the weed so i didn't do the
other stuff
okay i'm drinking on the weekends i'm
going out with the boys i'm wrecking
cars
i'm sleeping with everybody you know
well look now i made a list of those
things i don't do those things today
okay
i don't do any of that stuff today but
what other bad habits
what other bad habits am i doing today
that's throwing me off
i need to be aware of the enemy okay
it's called the enemy
the enemy okay the enemy ain't a person
the enemy ends up being people when you
ignore
the enemy at home man what i do is i put
dates
i get dates i was telling the mentors
this
i get dates and i put money on these
dates
okay i make investments that pull me
forward
they they forced me to go to the day
every one of you in a room did this by
the way you did it on this event right
here
congratulations you put some money here
then you put some airfare how many of
you
got a couple thousand dollars invested
in this event already in airfare
okay you got uh i don't know five six
seven eight hundred dollars invested in
hotels
ubers meals probably got three thousand
dollars invest in this
it pulled you forward right okay now
what you need is you need another one
right here another one here another one
here and another one here
just keep adding as many as you can to
keep pulling you to the next event
you know last night the astros won i'm
like damn i wonder if i could get that
thing tonight
i wonder if i could get that thing
tonight i wonder if it'd be possible to
get to that thing i could go to that
last
i get excited for a second
i would have to get back tomorrow
morning i got a 10 o'clock i got a 10
o'clock
uh one-on-one coaching at 10 a.m how do
i get to washington dc
finish with you guys today okay get to
dc tonight watch the game
fly back this morning and make by 10 a.m
see what i'm saying i want to
have things pulling me forward you need
that in your relationship too you need
it in your business and you need it for
your people
your people need to know hey but you
going here hey you're going here and
you're going to that thing
what are we doing there you're getting
educated that's why that daily meeting
every day with my people that todd was
talking about
every day they're doing that every
single day
okay and when people quit doing it we
know something's wrong
at the very least discipline's now out
of the organization the ethics are out
of the organization
the target was to educate every day it's
out
so it's either a manager right or it's
the people
hey why aren't you training anymore
well well good good you want to quit
or you already have you need an
accountability partner
you need someone that you share your
goals with that will hold you
accountable
a strong person somebody you respect a
mentor
a guide someone that you don't want to
disappoint
or let down pick someone that you can
have
with you on your side that you can share
as often as you need
to that your goals are this
your actions need to be that and you did
or didn't handle those things okay
and and have somebody in your life where
they'll hold you accountable and say
look come on man you're better than this
let's go
do this i've been using mentors my
entire life
a lot of people don't know this at the
age of 25 i had a mentor that met with
me
every single day to check on me every
day i made commitments every day
that person met with me every day when i
got into a sales game i was 26 27 years
old
i met with a guy every day to work with
me on my sales game
every day he held me accountable how
many calls i made how much
training i did every day i have had
accountability coaches and mentors
for 37 years
holding my hand holding me accountable
at my back pushing with pushing me when
i needed to push
pulling me when i needed to be pulled if
you think you're going to build
a brand because you create one great
video
it ain't going to happen so you need to
create a lot of content
one one masterpiece somebody somebody
said the other day they said i said you
post that video he's like he's not ready
yet i said you know what
a video post it's better than a video
that's perfect
true post the video i don't need it to
be perfect nobody's asking for perfect
okay so this is what this is why tvs are
dying
because the production on a tv show
takes so long
that by the time the tv show comes out
everybody's lost interest in it and
they're doing something else
i mean we have viewership on some of our
channels whether it's instagram facebook
or
youtube or twitter or linkedin or
snapchat we have lead we have viewership
higher than some tv channels in america
who spent billions of dollars
while they're producing while they're
planning
writing scripts we're producing content
you're just
just broadcasting you know we're
broadcasting okay and then and then so
so you can't
one masterpiece will not beat ten
thousand
uh pieces of content so number one
number two you you need to
you need to post frequently enough to
where you almost annoy your audience
okay uh that you gotta get you actually
have to get them through the annoying
part like oh you posted too much he's
posted too but you need to post
just a little bit more so they're like
oh wow this guy's
i can i can trust him now on the other
on the other side of the annoying is
i can trust him to post okay then the
third thing is you got to keep the
content entertaining and interesting
so you're not going to know how to do
that because you post once or twice and
and whatever you're doing this year
probably three or four or five years
from now you're going to look back and
say golly that was garbage
it's going to change i promise you so
you know i've posted i don't know 6 000
videos on youtube
um i don't know what i posted on
instagram a bunch
a couple thousand posts on instagram um
you know i i don't know what i'm doing
most of the time no it's
so just so everybody knows there is no
schedule there's no plan
the there's a commitment on a plan so
the commitment is say we are going
to tell the world show the world what
we're doing now whether that's me on my
jet or me just buying a new car
or me with my family i've been ridiculed
for all those things
he's using his kids for instagram i was
my kid dude
i didn't bring my kid to the to the live
show okay my kid walked in
while i was doing a show at nine o'clock
at night because she woke up
i'm not gonna stop the show because my
kid walks in my life any more than i'm
gonna stop
my life because my kid walks into my
life how do you control
how do you discipline how do you start
monitoring
what you're saying to yourself i can't
find the right girl
i can't find the right guy marriage is
hard
i'm broke i'm poor it's going to be hard
if you don't change your mind
you got to change the way you think and
a way to change the way you think
first of all the one way is to start
discipline yourself catch yourself
every time you say i don't have time say
hey i create time
every time you say i don't have money i
create money
literally like talking to yourself hey i
am a millionaire
so if you're broke right now quit saying
i am broke
and start saying what you want where are
you going it's not complicated you want
to get rich
i got rich you want to get rich you can
nothing and no one stopping you from
doing that
but the information in your head my
first book i wrote was called sell or be
sold it took three hours to write that
book
it was right after the economy collapse
which is part of what i want to share
with you today
the economy just collapsed in america i
owned three businesses at the time we
lived in los angeles california
i was just having a baby our first baby
i was 51 years old at the time
and the first baby was on the way i had
three companies
i was making a little money had had a
few had a few dollars in the bank
cars are paid for i had this freaking
great house
in los angeles it was lionel richie's
house
and me and ben affleck were bidding on
it and he
he he he he bitched out on himself
i bought the house and um
i had the life okay so what i want to
talk to you about today is
having the life and um
the economy collapse when lehman
collapsed the
life that i thought i had was put at
risk
so you're you're in this room because
you're a top producer
and i'm going to tell you that the the
one of the things that
to me is the most difficult thing in my
entire career
is becoming a top producer because the
moment you become a top producer
you become susceptible to thinking you
have the life
i grew up in a little town in louisiana
a little small town about 60
000 people you probably hear the accent
i grew up in a middle class a
middle-class family my
my dad died when i was 10 years old my
mother raised us and my mother
constantly told me how proud i should be
of myself
how many of you got a mother like that
you should be so proud of yourself
okay every time my mom was my best
friend and every time i would have a
success it didn't matter whether i was
18 years old or 48 years old
anytime i had a success she was the
first person i called i wouldn't call my
girlfriend wouldn't call my wife
wouldn't call any of
the people that were closest to me i
called my mom and said mom you never
believe i just bought a real estate deal
i started this company
i bought my first real estate deal it's
38 units it's 4 million
and she'd be like that's awesome i love
you just the way you are
and i'm like okay okay thanks she told
me that a thousand times how many had a
parent tell you
i love you that's great that's great you
made 160 grand last year
but i love you just the way you are let
me hear that
okay that's right out of the 10x rule i
don't know if you know that that's right
out of the four actions
anybody know what action is average
average i'm doing well okay there's four
levels of action number one is
i do nothing if i rewrote this book i
would take that out that's actually
impossible to do nothing at all it's
impossible try doing it right now
[Music]
to do nothing means you had to make a
decision to do something and not do it
this is actually not true i wouldn't put
it in the book if i rewrote it the
second level of action is
uh to retreat this is what most people
do by the way
how many had a commitment to work out
today and didn't
okay again i was up late whatever you
came up with
whatever reason i'm gonna make the call
by the way any retreat in life
any single retreat is a discipline
and a commitment to retreat when it
matters
so so every time you make a decision you
just need to be aware
that what are you doing here okay
there's only four things you can do in
any given day right you could do nothing
you could retreat or you could do this
average
now i know you guys are being told that
you're the top
you're the top you're the best you made
it to miami
but i'm just going to tell you right now
ain't it not a person in this room
is above number three
[Music]
no i'm not there okay and i know how
much i'm grinding every day how much i'm
pushing every day
how how many how many hours i put into a
day what's the maximum number of hours
you can do in a day
not if you had people
[Music]
if you added people you got to think
beyond the 24th thing once you guys get
committed once you get committed
then you will come up with solutions
outside the physical universe
okay you're already doing that your
space is your space is bizarre
okay here there's a bunch of people in
the room that
that like i don't know anything about
technology
i'm 61 years old i was born in 1958 i am
supposed to be outside
of that moment of technology yet i'm
probably one of the top five social
media people in the world today
banging on instagram and snapchat and
linkedin
and google plus that'll go away using
all these mechanisms to try to get
attention so that i can operate
at this level 10x thing this massive
level that
is always changing by the way you can't
10x something people were like man i'd
write the book if i wrote the book i'd
write it 11x
i'm like that's because you don't
understand 10x dude 10x is a multiplier
it's 10x which is 100.
okay so what what i do what i did in it
when lehman collapsed
i wrote the 10x rule and i wrote the
book because i realized i had done
something wrong that book was written
for me
and the reason when i closed the book
the reason i was like ah
whatever i had figured out what i had
done wrong okay
i had to embrace the the
the idea that three or four million
dollars in a bank and a house paid for
and two cars
and a marriage and i got it better than
everybody else and my mama loves me
just the way i am with all this
this middle class in america the middle
class
it is the sleeping chamber on planet
earth
okay people come here people come here
they come from india and china
come to here to get a middle class and i
don't want anything to do with this
okay your middle class you will not
change the world
you might change your house you might
change the education your little kids
get
okay they get to go to texas a m big
deal
right he told me that he went to texas i
said oh that had to screw you up bad
just going to college
wow because what are they manufacturing
college
they they manufacture average people at
college
so so i want to challenge you today okay
i want to challenge you today i want to
challenge you today to start thinking
hey wait a minute am i even a top
producer
how did that get created for this room
what number did you have to hit to get
in this room what's the number a million
who made that number up was that bob
i'm bob bob's sitting around what can we
do what can we do okay
did he make the number 1 million up
why wasn't it one million one hundred
thousand one ten
one one one instead because he got lazy
[Music]
one million is a lazy number how many
would agree with that
it's a lazy number do anything that ends
in a zero is lazy
come on how about some creativity right
how about a little creativity when
you're when you're making decisions in
your life
like what's a good income level for this
room let's say we don't share this
anywhere outside this room what would be
what would be a real number
you guys are going to hire me what's the
real number that i could make in this
room
y'all could talk to me how damn i i will
not hurt you okay
what's your number 400 grand okay now
why did we come up with that number
because i don't know how you guys could
even live on that number
[Music]
if if i made 400 grand a year i would be
embarrassed
with myself as a husband
a father basically as a human being
[Music]
400 grand how do you make sense of 35
000
a month you guys haven't done the math
you have not done the math because you
cannot live on 400 grand a year
and if you think you can live on 400
grand a year
i might have to go back and add number
one
[Music]
nothing anybody can make 400 grand a
year
all you got to do is show up okay now i
don't know
i don't know if i'm right or wrong you
guys don't need to agree with me i've
already been paid my fee
okay i am not here to satisfy you i am
not here so you like oh
oh grant i like him i don't care if you
like me or not man i want to move
a handful of people in the room to go
from 400 grand a year to start thinking
about how do i make 4 million
big boy right over here popping out what
would you make last year
what'd you gross last year 2.7
how does anybody live on 2.7 million
dollars a year
[Music]
you need to make it impossible dude i
cannot i can't my
my plane eats 2.7 million dollars a year
this dude needs to think different he's
running out of time man
you guys all in the room man you're
running out of time you're in a space
that is so frothy with opportunity it's
unbelievable
you're making sense of less than you can
get this is my mama my mama's saying
i love you boy just the way you are
mama i made 10 million dollars on one
deal
that's great but son i love you just the
way you are i'm like
i don't love me just the way i
am because i'm doing deals where i know
i could make a hundred okay how many of
you in a room are operating below your
potential
let me see your hand if you know you're
operating below your potential
man please tell me you're operating how
many of you let me see your hand again
if you're operating below your potential
okay your finances should indicate that
your finances are a way to tell the
truth about who you are
your space like if you're an uber driver
and you're making 2.7 million a year
pat on the back you're in this space
making 2.7 million a year come on man
your company's doing what two billion
two billion dollars and you guys aren't
getting it all would you say that you're
not getting it up
[Music]
a lot of room he's telling me he's in
the first innings of his game
so so i'm like hey what what do i need
to do let's say 400 is the number
then i'm gonna take this and i'm just
gonna 10x that and i'm gonna build a
business plan
for four million dollars and i'm gonna
quit thinking
i'm gonna quit thinking that i that i
gotta do a four minute mile
i'm gonna quit thinking about the
physical universe
what can i do to produce four million
dollars worth of income
[Music]
is it here is it outside of here is it
here and outside of here how many
customers would i need
this is what this is what my goal for
you today is to leave here and say dude
i ain't satisfied
okay i want to raise the numbers on this
room
so the next time there's 75 people here
and everybody adds a zero to your income
oh by the way if you love yourself at
400 grand mama
if you love your son just the way he is
at 400 would you love me a little more
if i had a zero no she couldn't love me
anymore
it wasn't up to her to love me it was up
to me to love what i'm doing every day
right you guys are showing up you're
working your ass off every day right or
wrong
how many of you making calls every day
you're like i do not want to make this
call and you make it anyway
good then get paid for it get paid some
real money for it man
okay get paid some real money just had a
zero
how many calls would i have to make is
this even possible
he's doing part of it he told me i'm not
he's not tapped into all of it
he's hitting 70 of that number if
everybody walked out of here and said
hey i'm gonna build a four million
dollar plan
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you a
little a little game i play i got 14
little companies i run 14 little
companies
while i'm doing deals while i'm speaking
to you today right i'm still running
them in my head right now i got them all
open
i got browsers open all over the place
counselor said you got add i said i got
add i don't know how to add i multiply
i'm done ad i'm done adding a customer i
want to multiply customers
i want to i don't want to add orders i
want to multiply my orders okay
i consider myself a decent sales person
but it doesn't matter if you're a great
salesperson
if you don't add business to the sale if
you don't become a business person
you can't build out zeros now i've got
some special bonus clips that i think
you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free in the first line of
the description below and if you're
enjoying this billionaire mindset series
give me a hashtag
billionaire mindset in the comments
below so i can celebrate you
the mind is getting in your own way if
you want to lose weight
you know how to do it you got to eat
less you got to work out more you will
lose weight
why are you not doing it self-discipline
your mind is getting in your way
but i see self-discipline as a positive
i think self-discipline has a really
negative connotation a lot of times i
think
in a lot of the messages that people are
putting out it comes across as this
really negative thing like
you have to force yourself to do all the
stuff that you really hate
and it's going to suck but you have to
keep going you got to do it you got to
be disciplined if you're not disciplined
you suck
everything's terrible it just comes
across as this really negative
forcing yourself to do stuff that
doesn't resonate with me
i see self-discipline as a really
positive thing i think it's really
helpful i think it's amazing and
beautiful and golden
let's look at weight as an example i am
the lowest weight that i've been
all year i'm on a routine it's working
the specific strategies that don't
really matter one
intermediate fasting so i'll only have
water and a coffee
until noon and then after that i'll
start eating i do that seven days a week
i run for 30 minutes uh usually at night
while i'm watching a show with my wife
seven days a week and then six days a
week i'll restrict my calories not
really forcing myself not to eat food
just not eating doritos and not eating
junk right eating healthy food six days
a week and then saturdays i get to do
what i want
six days a week those are the strategies
that i use it may seem like torture
but it's not and the thing that helps me
get through it is the mindset
because the positive of all of this is
i'm losing
weight i'm feeling great i'm making
progress i'm i'm super pumped that i'm
getting closer to my goal
i feel amazing about myself so i think
self-discipline
usually it seems to focus just on the
action that you just have to grind your
way through it
without enough focus on the mission of
what you're trying to accomplish and how
beautiful and wonderful that is
and so yes some of it might suck
right but you're moving towards
something amazing and beautiful
so i think people just focus too much on
the negative part of it and and if you
force yourself to do something that you
hate you can only do it for so long
before you give up
if you can't tie it into the bigger
picture of what you're trying to
accomplish
then you will give up and you will quit
and you will feel terrible and then i
think
having other people yell at you but how
you need to have self-discipline doesn't
actually help
i think it actually makes it worse
because you develop the identity for
yourself
of i don't have any self-discipline you
can build it it's not that difficult to
do
in my perspective in my view all you
need to do is make sure that you have a
really strong why
make sure that you have a an outcome
that you are really looking forward to
and you love doing
and then the process itself how do you
make the process as enjoyable as
possible
how do you make the process just not
absolutely suck every single day going
in
right if you figure that out then you
win at the end of the day this is a
mindset game
every single goal that you want to
accomplish is a mindset game the thing
that's holding you back is not your lack
of knowledge
it's not your lack of creativity it's
your mindset it's your
it's your perspective it's your view you
can figure out the answer to any
question
quite easily it doesn't mean you will
execute it on it because your mindset is
broken
nothing else you already have everything
you need to win and so discipline is
really important
i just try to tie it into some bigger
picture thing that i'm trying to
accomplish
that is more important than any minor
pain that i have to struggle through in
the moment
and uh that's my perspective there will
be moments in your business where you
will need to have
super human strength to keep going where
it just demands
everything from you every single ounce
that you have
but if you need to have super human
energy every single day
you're gonna burn out and fail so
whenever i want to try something new
when i'm testing something new
i always eat into some of my reserves it
may mean to go off into this new project
i'm going to sleep less i spend a little
bit
less time working on my book or a little
less time work on my youtube channel
right you eat into these reserves
but that's not sustainable if that's
what you're doing constantly you're
going to be unhappy you're going to burn
out you're going to fail
so quick example uh sad guru came to
toronto if you don't know he's a yogi
he's an indian mystic
we did a top 10 on him he then invited
me to come to his event in toronto and
then do a one-on-one
interview with him uh close to the
toronto airport the island
was amazing great time out of that he
says evan i want you to come to my
multi-day event in the us i want you to
come be a vp guest there
it'd be amazing to have you awesome but
before you do that
you have to do my seven-day program
where you have to meditate every day for
seven days and i think it's an hour plus
every day i didn't have an hour a day
right i mean that's not
part of what i had in my calendar every
hour in my calendar
is accounted for it doesn't mean i'm
working all that time but
i might be spending time with my wife
i'd be spending time with my son
every hour is accounted for and so to do
this i had to eat into some of my
reserves
and so for that one i asked nina said
nina
if you're going to come with me you have
to do this too do we want to spend our
hour in the evening instead of watching
a show instead of relaxing
to to do this program for seven days for
meditation and she said yes
and so here's the thing we did it for
seven days and we went to the event it
was awesome
if it was something that we were going
to continue if we were gonna meditate
every day
for an hour ongoing then i'd have to
readjust my schedule
your success comes from your habits you
need to figure what a balanced life
looks like for you
now ultimately i don't meditate an hour
every night i do some healing meditation
for my neck
every morning but that habit didn't
stick
and that's okay so when you're testing
new habits testing
ideas testing something for your
business or some
emergency comes up that you have to deal
with it's gonna tap into your reserves
you can't be running your business at
full capacity already you can't be
running your business on
zero on empty because that means there's
no extra gear that means that when
life punches you in the face you can't
handle it that means if you want to try
or taste or test something else
you can't do it because you have no
reserves you have no battery there's no
more gas in the tank
and so that's where a lot of
entrepreneurs live that that's where
it's really troublesome that's where a
lot of entrepreneurs will end up burning
out failing
and crushing their dreams because you're
just running with no gas left in the
tank
and so you can stretch yourself i think
that's normal i think that's okay i
think life will hit you in the face and
just when you think it couldn't get
worse
here comes another punch that will
happen but it's making sure that you can
live that balanced life whatever balance
looks like for you
so how do you handle these things when
they come up i'm going to give you a
three-step process
that i think will help step number one
is tell yourself it's the best
when life punches you in the face when
you get some crisis that happens
i try to run a no-crisis business but
that is not always possible
stuff will still happen and if it's not
in your business life it'll happen in
your personal life
when life punches you in the face and
you can't get out of it and you have to
address it you have to deal with it
instead of living in the land of
negativity and complaining and why me
and despair
and desperation i flip it i complain for
eight and a half seconds and then say
this is the best
this is the it's the best this is the
best thing ever
because what it does is it puts you in a
state of resourcefulness
it puts you in a place where you can
then go and solve the problem
so i'm going to meditate for an hour and
nights is the best
right i'm sitting next to the smelly
dude on the airplane it's the best
because what's the alternative you're
stuck next to the smelly guy on the
airplane what's the alternative
the alternative is you sit on the plane
and you're upset and you freak out and
you complain and you're negative and
grumpy and unhappy
and that's not gonna allow you to create
beautiful amazing things for your
business or your life
so when you're forced into that
situation when when life hits you by
surprise
tell yourself this is the best this is
your chance to prove to yourself and the
world what you're actually made of
step number two is if this is an ongoing
problem then you need to fix your life
if it's every single day that this is
happening then
you can't tell yourself it's the best
every day because it's the best allows
you to tap into those reserves
it allows you to find that extra little
bit of juice in the gas tank to keep
going
and solve this big problem but if it's
every day that you're stressed out to
the max that you're not sleeping that
you have no energy that you're hating
the work that you're
doing you need to fix your life
you can't get up every day and just tell
yourself it's the best because you're
gonna run out of energy there's no
reserves left you will fail
you will disappoint yourself you will
just run out
and so you are what you consistently do
you look at your calendar
and there's something in there that is
broken you need to fix your life
if every day you are stressed out and in
step number three is schedule for
success
so so your habits will dictate your
success your actions need to map to your
ambitions
what balance looks like for you needs to
be reflected
in your habits you can say here's what
balance looks like for me but if you're
not living it you're not going to be
happy and you're going to run out of
energy and you're going to burn out and
you're going to start to hate your life
so what does a balanced life look like
for you how much time do you want to
spend with your family
with your significant other on your
business on yourself personal
development
working out singing hobbies dancing
friends whatever it is that you want to
do what is a balanced life for you look
like and this is something that only you
can judge what i do
what the rock does what satguru does
what dan lok does what anybody that we
profile whatever they do what elon musk
does
don't compare yourself to elon musk and
his schedule you can use his schedule
as guidance as an idea as here's
something that somebody is doing that is
possible
but maybe that's not for you you try on
the hat and then you see so you have to
decide what does bounce look like for
you
and then take out your calendar every
day of the week from sunday to the next
sunday
and put everything in here's how much
time i want to spend on these different
activities
because if you want balance and it looks
like this and then you look at your
calendar and it's totally different
you're gonna run out of energy and not
like your life schedule for success
hard work is your ticket in it doesn't
guarantee your success
there are tons of people who work hard
and are living at the poverty line
but there is nobody who wins and doesn't
work hard
working hard is your ticket in one of
the
biggest reasons why i've won on youtube
is because i've been making three videos
a day for the past five plus years
three videos a day for five plus years
there there have been
one or two days where maybe i missed one
video
not three videos not an entire day off
maybe one video
once or twice in five years that's it
it's just been a testament to
consistency every single day
videos have to go live on the channel
and i film through everything i've
filmed through
having broken my neck right in two spots
i've filmed through having a concussion
i filmed through being sick i filmed
through completely losing my voice
and then having to to pull up pieces of
paper with the notes
written on and i filmed through
everything i think there's a lot of
people who
who i look up to who i think are way
better than me people who have way more
talent than me who are
way more natural than i am at making
videos and expressing themselves
and i've passed them because i just
worked harder
because i just kept going because i kept
making the content one of the biggest
reasons why
you are not more successful is you're
just not consistently working hard
enough at it
this game of entrepreneurship whether
you're trying to be a youtuber or
something totally different
it's are you getting up every single day
and doing the thing that you have to do
because you're gonna get punched in the
face there's gonna be so many setbacks
even today this morning my wife had a
rough night last night she had allergies
she woke up at four in the morning
had to to take some pills and just had a
really rough night and and that set us
back on our morning routine
right we have our morning routine we go
through our five and a half s's
every morning we start off with with
singing or put some music on
then sun then soar and then sweat and
then scare
and we got set back by half an hour by
by her having a late night and this is
where
so many people fall down when you have
something that throws you off schedule
right
when you're sick when when life hits you
in the face
when a distraction comes up an emergency
happens
how do you respond because if you only
work hard when you have ideal conditions
you're never going to build a great
business we were set back half an hour
today
right what do we do the same five and a
half s's
let's go how you respond matters and so
whatever's happening in your life right
now there's so many reasons why you
can't win there's so many reasons why
you
you shouldn't get up and work lots of
reasons reasons that are justifiable
the reasons not to work on your business
are justifiable
and if you ask your friends who are
non-entrepreneurs or at least
non-successful entrepreneurs
they'll let you off the hook tell your
friends yeah i lost my voice like oh you
can't make videos
you tell your friends i broke my neck oh
yeah yeah you can't make videos
right they'll let you off the hook but
these are not the people
who have standards that you aspire to
don't allow the low standards of your
friends
prevent you from doing the thing that
you should be doing
and so how you respond to these
emergencies and these life situations
that happen
matters it means something you
with less talent right you might be
introverted you might you might have
less talent you might have less skills
you might not be naturally gifted at it
you can win
this is how you win by working hard
every single day are you proud of your
effort
when i was still on my tour even though
i broke my neck
my quality wasn't as high post breaking
my neck
versus pre breaking my neck in terms of
doing the workshops but i was proud of
my effort
are you proud of your effort and if you
can sustainably say that you're proud of
your effort if you can wake up every day
you know my wife is tired today
she'll take a little bit slower today
but is she proud of her effort
are you proud of your effort if every
day you wake up
and then you do work and you're proud of
your effort i promise you you're gonna
win
if you can sustain that for weeks
for months for years you'll win
where the problem for too many people is
you're working really hard one day and
then
you fall back and then really hard one
day and then you fall back
and that applies not just to
entrepreneurship it's life you're you're
really hard working on your diet and
then you fall off you're really hard
working out in the gym
and then you fall off it's the
consistency that matters
it's the working hard every single day
you are what you consistently do
and i want to see you guys win okay
great so how do you actually develop
a brutal work ethic i'm going to give
you a three-step process you can follow
let's do it
step number one is you have to do
something you love right i mean you can
only force yourself to do something that
you hate for so long before you give up
of all the people that i profile right
consistently across
athletics to entrepreneurship to
politicians to musicians singers
all across the spectrum people who've
had success
the number one rule that keeps coming up
over and over and over and over again
is they love what they do you have to
enjoy the process
you like the work i like making videos i
like speaking entrepreneurs
right i like it if you are forcing
yourself to do something that you hate
you will quit you just will it's gonna
be too hard and so
why spend all this time doing work that
you hate just chasing some opportunity
when you could actually focus those
efforts on something you love to do and
get results that nobody else can
you have to do stuff that you love
number two is tell yourself that you do
difficult things
this is how you build self-love this is
how you build self-confidence this is
how you build self-respect
you do difficult things you like to do
difficult things
and and it's not just a mindset trick
like you actually do
you don't want to live the same life
over and over and over and over and over
again
you don't want a boring life you don't
want to just stay inside your comfort
zone
and so to leave your comfort zone that
requires doing difficult things
and so whenever you're looking at a
challenge that's in front of you
you're looking at a goal that's in front
of you you're looking at an outcome that
you're trying to go after and chase
what's the reason that you're telling
yourself why you can't do it if it's
well it's difficult that's not an
acceptable reason catch yourself
and ask your friends and your family the
people close to you to catch you too
anytime that you say well that's hard
that's difficult
and you do difficult things you need to
change the wiring
you like doing difficult things the fact
that it's hard makes it amazing
you don't want to do easy things for the
rest of your life do you do you want to
just do
easy things for the rest of your life no
you want to do difficult things you love
difficult things
so watch the language watch the words
you're telling yourself watch your
thought process
if the reason why you're not achieving
your goals is because it's hard it's
difficult that's not a good enough
reason
because you do difficult things and then
idea number three is be the tree
i love using this analogy the idea is
you're a tree you're an entrepreneur
you're tree what do trees do
well trees they breathe in carbon
dioxide
right poison they breeze in carbon
dioxide if you have too much as a human
you will die from carbon dioxide
the they breathe it in they eat it right
they eat it they grow from it and then
they spit out
positivity oxygen for the world that's
your job
that's your job as a leader that's your
job as an entrepreneur
your job is to eat the negativity to eat
the poison to eat the difficulty
and then create something better for the
world
it's service whatever this challenging
thing is that you have to deal with
whatever you're trying to work so hard
on whatever you need to develop a better
work ethic on
when you do it you'll be able to help
other people do it as well
and if you believe like i believe that
humans are built to serve
then you're going to be able to help
other people because your purpose comes
from your pain
because the thing that you struggle the
most with once you figure it out once
you get through it
what will make you come alive for the
rest of your life is helping other
people who are currently going through
that thing
so you're a tree this is what you're
meant to do this is what you're born to
do this is what you love doing
you're supposed to breathe in the poison
eat it grow from it
and then make the world around you a
better place the people who win
work the hardest because they love what
they do they put in the hours and the
hours and the hours and the hours for
days and days and days and weeks and
weeks and weeks and months and months
and months
and years and years and years because
they love it because it's not work for
them
the only way you're going to be willing
to put in the work that is necessary to
win to be the best in your industry
the only way you're gonna put in that
amount of work is because you love what
you're doing
and if you don't you're gonna you're
gonna lose because there's gonna be
somebody who will love it
who loves it more than you and will
crush you and you'll you'll be not even
a number two you'll be
mediocre because there's lots of people
who love what they do and there's lots
of people grinding it and working hard
if you are looking at your calendar like
open up your account look what you're
gonna do today or look what you're doing
tomorrow
what's on the schedule if you're looking
at it and you're like oh
i gotta do all these things if that's
your reaction
you might be in the wrong business now
if it's a one-off thing if there's a
one-day you know you got to deal with
the government or
something fine but if that's
daily if that's consistent if that's
always happening if you
continue to look at your calendar and
you're you're upset
and depressed and angry you're in the
wrong business
the work should feel like
something exciting to go and do where
other people might jump into your
schedule and say that's crazy
i could never do that that's great
that's why you're not crushing it like i
am like go
go crush it in your field go do your
thing
as an example here's one change that
i've made to my youtube channel
you may have noticed this month
the video series look a little different
i'm working with a videographer
jason and the only way we can make this
thing work was if we did it on one day
so i used to film
my videos once a week on a wednesday for
the week
and jason works by the day said okay you
know what i want to increase the quality
of the videos i wanted to look
more hollywood do we look more hollywood
is it looking nice do you guys like the
quality give a thumbs up for jason down
in the comments
and the way to make it work was to do it
once a month and so
i'm sitting here filming my videos for
the month we're doing like
70 videos in one day grinding them
through
i've got two extra large coffees got one
sitting behind here
halfway through that and here's the
thing to make this work
it's a lot of extra pressure on my team
to get a lot of things ready and sooner
and faster
right so my team's been working extra
hard to get it
ready for this one time and if we
continue it it's their usual job it's
not as stressful or hard
i'm thinking about them i don't want
them to stress out too much
but really the person who has the
hardest is me because for me it's not
just
a one-off thing this is now going to be
every month like do i have the
ability to stay on to have energy
for an entire day can i get through
making 70 videos
in a single day i don't know but when
jason and i are on email we're trying to
figure this out
and i look at how hard it was gonna be
for me to do to be on camera for that
long
i'm like i gotta do this this is awesome
i might crash and burn and like it
doesn't work out and it totally fails
and i can't handle the
the length and the time but i want to
try
where so many people have a hard time
making one or two videos
a month here we are making 70 in a day
crushing it all down and i love it
it's hardest on me versus anybody else
on my team but i don't even think about
it because
i i love the challenge i love the
ability to work that hard and see if i
can do it
and see if it makes sense for what we're
trying to do what do you guys think you
like
you like these videos like this you want
more of it let me know leave a comment
and so in thinking about that i don't
think that i'm super special by the way
i just found the thing that i love doing
i'm willing to put in this kind of
hustle and work because i love making
the videos because i want to
create more and better content for you
guys
you could put in that same amount of
drive energy hustle that i'm doing today
in your business but it's not going to
happen if you look at your schedule and
like
like this i was looking at my schedule
last night and like i'm so excited about
tomorrow i'm so excited about tomorrow
it's so good i can see how it goes
let's try to crush it right and again
not every day is going to be super
amazing
but you should love the work that you do
net net you should be excited about the
day that is ahead
net net and not feeling sad depressed
angry frustrated about the work that you
have to do the people who win
work the hardest because they love what
they do if you want to sign up for the
entire billionaire mindset series for
free and get the companion bonus pdf
calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there